[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée aux 40 ans de 50 ans en
Eveline on a déjà parlé ici de culture
de
santé de transport on va parler
aujourd'hui d'économie parce qu'après
tout cqu en Eveline c'est peut-être
d'abord un Paris économique mais comment
faire venir les entreprises c'était
peut-être pas un Paris gagné d'avance
pour en parler François deignier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le maire de guancour
et vous êtes vice-président de la casqu
chargée des affaires économiques Henry
vatrin vous êtes vice-président de la
commission formation de la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
bonjour bonjour HERV de bonjour vous
êtes directeur de l'espace
Saint-Quentin SK West saqutin sky ou
bonjour et bonjour et Jean-Luc Merot
vous êtes directeur de la Maison de
l'Entreprise on verra dans quelques
instants qu'est-ce que c'était que cette
Maison de l'Entreprise alors on va
commencer bah comme toujours par évoquer
les les premières années le passé les
premières
années alors François delier je vais
commencer avec vous parce qu'évidemment
le le le Paris quand quand la communauté
a commencé d'exister même avant que la
communauté proprement dit existe c'était
de faire venir des des entreprises c'est
de de faire un tissu économique de créer
un tissu économique comment ça s'est
passé qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait alors c'était vraiment créé une
ville nouvelle à l'époque le général de
Gaulle avait demandé à de l'ouvrier
autour de Paris quelques endroits clés
stratégiques pour développer des
nouvelles villes villes nouvelles et et
donc qui dit ville dit évidemment
logement mais aussi activité et de ce
point de vue-là il y a eu un grand
volontarisme de la part de l'État dès
les années 70 on a eu les premières zone
d'activité avec l'établissement public
d'aménagement plus tard dans les années
80 des grands groupes qui sont arrivés
comme des locomotives je pense par
exemple à à à bouig
même juste avant on avait eu également
par exemple le Crédit Agricole
île-de-fance donc des grandes
locomotives et en même temps l'arrivée
d'un tissu économique j'allais dire
diversifié avec petites et moyennes
entreprises également alors le premier
pas vous vous avez raison de le dire
c'était l'établissement public
d'aménagement qui va essayer quoi
d'attirer d'abord quoi des artisans
c'était le premier le Paris c'était
quand même de faire venir des des des
grands groupes hein je me sou la DATAR
faisant venir alors je citais le le le
Crédit Agricole mais on pourrait penser
par exemple à malakov qui est maintenant
malakov méi qui est toujours d'ailleurs
sur le territoire qui a trouvé un nouvel
emplacement mais qui était là dès
l'origine il y avait une volonté de
faire que des grands groupes puissent
euh venir démarrer et avoir un effet
d'entraînement finalement et qu'est-ce
qu'on leur dit alors pour pour les
pervenir alors vous étiez pas en place à
l'époque mais c'é c'était les conditions
d'arrivée en fait hein c'était les
conditions d'arrivée négocié par le
l'État avec les les les grandes
entreprises et et avec un objectif
c'était d'inciter alors pour les grandes
entreprises à l'époque toute la
difficulté c'est est-ce que les salariés
est-ce que les collaborateurs
d'entreprise allait vouloir venir ce qui
est très intéressant c'est justement
quelques décennies après de voir que les
premiers groupes installés ceux que je
viens de citer quand vous discutez avec
les responsables quand vous discutez
avec les drage vous voyez que le nombre
d'employés qui sont devenus des
habitants euh s'est développé et donc il
y a vraiment eu un effet eu d' c'était
des gens qui venaient d'ailleurs etc dé
travaillé et et qui sont implantés
installés ici hein c'est ça voilà et ce
qui fait que on a maintenant plus de 38
% de de d'actifs cquantinois qui qui
travaillent à 50 an yeline mais certains
au départ sont venus d'ailleurs ils sont
sont arrivés là où venait s'installer
l'entreprise ont choisi de de résider et
et d'y faire leur vie finalement c'était
facile pour les première je peux poser
la question à vin pour les premières
entreprises c'était facile de venir
s'installer ici ou c'était un peu un
saut dans l'inconnu j'imagine que pour
les Tau de première c'était ça tenait du
du saut à l'inconnu dans l'inconnu c'est
certain bon nous on est arrivé vers les
années 90 euh la motivation c'était
d'abord un terrain suffisamment grand
pour y implanter une entreprise de
j'ai pas précisé vous êtes directeur du
site de Thales hein c'est ça absolument
oui donc quand Thalès est venu
s'installer il cherchait de quoi
installer 3000 personnes donc 100000 m²
de de de bureau et et d'atelier et puis
le le deuxème point déterminant c'est
l'accueil on a trouvé sur place en 90
alors je sais pas ce que les gens ont
trouvé en 84 mais en 90 on a trouvé des
gens pour répondre à nos question et des
gens pour répondre aux questions de nos
salariés que soit pas nous qui portions
exclusivement le les contraintes du
transfert d'ù l'implantation qui se fait
c'est simpimp et le évidemment enfin je
pense que après il y a un effet
c'estàdire que si si des entreprises
comme thalè par exemple s'implante ça
attire évidemment d'autres entreprises
c'est c'est certain oui même même des
entreprises de ta équivalente en disons
alors il y il y a aussi bah il y a aussi
les les les vous qui vous installez
faites les 25 ans hein oui 25 ans du
centre commercial centre commercial bah
le commerce c'est la vie donc il fallait
aussi re pourvoyeur de de commerce pour
toutes ces entreprises qui
s'installaient donc maintenant euh
l'espace 51 c'est 120 boutiques c'est 13
millions de visiteurs par an euh on a un
hypermarché qui est le dans les dans les
top 100 en France et associé à un autre
notre établissement qui a vu lieu sur
l'axe loisir en 2005 on a maintenant une
offre de 200 boutiques et et un un pôle
cinéma qui est le 6e de France aussi
pour pour divertir t toute cette cette
populationz beaucoup de demandes oui oui
tout à fait oui oui bien sûr là euh tout
récemment la semaine dernière on a on a
accueilli une enseigne très connu qui
fait du café à
l'américaine mais quand ça s'est créé il
y a 25 ans là aussi il Ava fallu faire
un effort pour attirer euh oui alors
bien sûr c'est c'est un accompagnement
financier c'est un projet aussi
architectural qui peut plaire et puis
c'est dans les aides financières pour
accompagner pour stabiliser les emplois
on emploie 1500 personnes quand même sur
sur ce site commercial alors parmi les
entreprises qui se sont implantées il y
a eu Renault avec avec le Technocentre
je vous propose de de revoir un sujet
peut-être il y a qui l'ont déjà vu
peut-être d'autres qui l'ont pas vu
parce qu'il date de de l'installation de
ce tech au centre de
Renault la nouvelle est tombée sans
surprise la semaine dernière le permis
de construire de la ruche première
tranche du Technocentre Renault est
annulé c'est le deuxième coup d'arrêt
porté à la régie par le tribunal
administratif de Versailles aès après la
suspension des travaux obtenus en
novembre dernier par l'association
écologique Eveline environnement cette
décision remet en cause la validité
juridique de la zone d'aménagement
concerté de Villarois sur laquelle doit
être construit le Technocentre raison
principale de cette sanction l'enquête
publique et l'étude d'impact de la
construction sur l'environnement
conditionnelle à la création de la ZAC
serait incomplète ce qui pose le
problème de quatre autres permis de
construire attribués à Renault par la
préfecture à l'établissement public
d'amén ement de la ville nouvelle
aménageur juridique de la ZAC pour le
compte de Renault on confesse du bout
des lèvres cette imperfection il n'y
aura pourant pas de reprise des travaux
sans que les pouvoirs publics présentent
après nouvelle enquête un projet de ZAC
viable côté Renault même si on se refuse
à tout commentaire dans les bureaux du
Technocentre il est clair que la régie
ne fera pas appel pas question donc de
faire machine arrière ce projet
d'envergure 380000 m² de bureau et de
surface technique sur 148 hectares de
terrain au total doit aboutir pour
réaliser des gains de temps sur les
futurs prototypes dans l'attente de ces
gains de temps futur Renault doit faire
face à un sérieux retard évalué à 10
mois environ et privant de travail
quelques 2000 personnes d'ici la reprise
des travaux le plateau de Villarois avec
ses quelques baraquements isolés
continuera à donner cette image de
désarois d'un chantier aujourd'hui dans
l'impasse
alors on va passer à l'époque du
développement c'est c'est c'est
intéressant de voir que le Technocentre
au fond c'était pas il y avait des
réticences au moment de l'installation
il y a eu des procédures he il y a eu
des procédures ça ça nous rappelle c'est
intéressant parce que ça rappelle que
l'implantation d' entreprise c'est
toujours ça ne va pas de soi c'est
toujours un combat il faut avoir une
vision déterminée là il a fallu lever
des obstacles vous vous avez vu de de
procédures en fait juridico
administratif mais au-delà de ça c'est
quand même intéressant quand on dit
Villarois sorte de plateau des désolé et
qu'on voit maintenant la vie avec le
Technocentre mais aussi tout ce qui
s'est fait dans ce secteur est de de Guy
encs à à 50 anilleur quelques chiffres
qui sont assez impressionnants pour
revenir au premier temps quand même en
74 il y a quand même 40000 emplois dans
la dans la ville nouvelle et entre 75 et
79 250 entreprises quand même se sont
installées c'est quand même absolument
exceptionnel et alors là on arrive
évidemment ce dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure c'està dire les années 80 90
avec la a des grandes entreprises big
d'assaau l'aérospatial Renault qu'on
vient de voir et puis le centre
commercial évidemment qu' qu'on connait
tel qu'on le connaitt aujourd'hui enfin
presque tel qu'on le connait aujourd'hui
en tout cas là là encore alors là c'est
devenu quand même quelque chose qui
compte sur le plan économique la la la
communauté Saint-Quentin en
Saint-Quentin voilà tout à fait au-delà
des des premières arrivées qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure dans les années
que vous citez l'enjeu pour les élus
parce qu'on a pas que l'établissement
publics d'aménagement il y a eu la
collec activité avec les les communes
mais également avec ce qui n'était pas
encore la communauté d'agglomération
mais qu'on appelait le SAN et encore
avant le le scan il y a une volonté des
élus une compréhension des élus du fait
qu'il fallait il fallait développer une
attractivité pour qu'une entreprise
Vienne il faut proposer un cadre de vie
et une attractivité suffisante l'enjeu
c'était celui du logement pouvoir
accueillir dans les logements et ça
reste une vraie question
d'ailleurs bien sûr si vous parlez au
chef d'entreprise la question du
logement est toujours importante comme
celle du
déplacement avec l'accessibilité et la
manière de de pouvoir se déplacer les
différents moyens et au-delà de ça ce
sont aussi les services proposés à la
population le cadre de vie et finalement
tout ce qui compose une attractivité qui
fait que un chef d'entreprise pourra
faire le choix de 50 ans en yeline parce
qu'il sait que ces
salariés voilà il il sait que ces
salariés pourront trouver euh un lieu de
vie
avec avec y compris tout ce qu'on peut
évoquer en terme de culture de loisirs
et cetera hen
vin je parle alors au patron de Thalas
chez vous quelle est la proportion de
gens qui habitent sur le territoire vous
le savez ça oui oui elle reste encore
faible vous savez qu'on a fait des plans
de déplacement en entreprise euh donc
ces nous ont révélé que chez nous 80
% de nos salariés n'habitent pas à
sa-qutinou et c'est un problème pour
vous enfin bien sûr c'est un problème
c'est un problème pour eux donc par
conséquence problème pour nous parce que
compte tenu de la saturation des
transports il passe un temps important 1
heure quelque fois de voire plus par
jour dans les transports et c'est c'est
bon pour personne et c'est clair que
c'est un frein au au développement si on
y remédie pas rapidement avec ce que je
disais des implantations de euh des
implantation de salariés dans
Saint-Quentin et et j'insisterai plus
particulièrement sur les jeunes des
entreprises comme les nôtres quand elles
se développent elles embauchent et et
les jeunes eux n'ont pas d' priori ils
habitent pas la région parisienne
nécessairement donc ils sont prêts à
venir à condition d'y trouver par ce que
vous venez de dire des logements en
location plus c'est pas tellement
l'environnement c'est les logements en
fond si je oui ou oui je CIS les
logements bon logement et transport
voilà Jean-Luc Moo la la la Maison de
l'Entreprise elle est créée à la fin des
années 90 quel en je elle répond alors
on a on a beaucoup parlé des grands
groupes notamment avec l'arrivée de de
Thalès et c'est vrai que à la fin des
années 90 la la question notamment du
développement des PME s'est posé c'est
dire que Saint-Quentin c'est c'est une
agglomération qui s'est principalement
construite sur le en s'appuyant sur
l'arrivée de de grands groupes mais vous
le savez un tissu économique ne peut
être équilibré que si effectivement
autour de ces grands groupes on a aussi
des PME qui gravitent et qui permettent
à ces entreprises de se développer donc
c'est plutôt à elle que vous vous
adressez VO dire effectivement
l'objectif premier absolument c'est
vraiment d'appuyer les entreprises mais
les PME principalement à la fois dans
leur phase de création mais aussi dans
leur dans leur développement donc en
1999 le SAN à l'époque qui s'est
transformé en communauté d'agglomération
par la suite a mobilisé un certain
nombre d'acteurs économiques privés
public alors disant voilà on est sur un
territoire qui est riche qui se
développe mais qui aurait peut-être
besoin ou non d'ailleurs de structure
pour essayer de de rendre à la fois
lisible tous les dispos positif existant
mais aussi leur leur donner une vraie
complémentarité et les mettre en
relation et les mettre en relation donc
c'était vraiment l'enjeu de départ donc
toutes ces structures que ce soit les
chambres consulaires ou ou ou d'autres
structures je dis publi et privé bah
était d'accord sur le fait que
finalement avoir une synergie ou une
force mobilisatrice et fédératrice de
tout ça pouvait donner du sens au
développement de sa-anta d'où la
création la CRÉ de cette maison de cette
maison d'entreprise euh on parlait de
dasto de B de talè de Renault mais il y
a aussi des entreprises UNIP
personnelles heinsolument ouis et c'est
fondamental pour l'équilibre de
territoire vous recceevez enfin
absolument donc notre rôle bon
principalement il tourne autour de
quatre axes aujourd'hui un rôle lié à la
création d'entreprise et là
effectivement on s'adresse beaucoup plus
au au TPE au PME un rôle également
d'animation économique du territoire
donc on organise et là on s'appuie et on
travaille aussi et surtout peut-être
avec des entreprises de plus grosse
dimension talè ou d'autres un rôle
également de financement on sa que le
financement est un élément capital dans
le développement ou la création d'une
entreprise donc on a mis en place
toujours avec les structures dont on
parlait qui sont partenaires de cette
maison d'entreprise on a mis en place un
dispositif de financement récemment et
puis euh on parlera sans doute de
perspective tout à l'heure mais l'enjeu
des réseaux est un enjeu important donc
on a beaucoup d'action en ce moment
autour des réseaux d'entreprise alors je
voudrais revenir à une mesure qui a fait
débat ENF qui été prise par le
gouvernement c'est la suppression de de
la taxe professionnelle qui était une
man évidemment je suppose ça pour pour
la communauté deoméation ça fait
peut-être plaisir au au chefs
d'entreprise vous nous le direz en tout
cas cette suppression a été décidé on va
revenir sur ce sujet de la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle la taxe
professionnelle existe depuis
1975 versé par les entreprises c'est
l'un des quatre impôts directs qui
alimentent les finances locales à
Saint-Quentin c'est l'agglomération qui
collecte la taxe professionnel sur les
SEP communes sont pris en compte
notamment la taille des entreprises la
valeur de leurs locaux et leurs chiffre
d'affaires c'est ce que l'on appelle la
base d'imposition à 50 an en Yveline
pour l'ensemble des entreprises elle
s'élève à 523 million d'euros selon les
estimations prévues pour 2009 la taxe
professionnelle est ensuite calculée en
multipliant cette base d'imposition avec
le taux voté par la collectivité à
Saint-Quentin il est de 18,40 %. ainsi
dans le budget 2009 l'agglomération a
prévu que la taxe professionnelle lui
rapporte
96434682 € en 2009 sachez enfin que
depuis 2007 le montant de la taxe
professionnelle est plafonné à 3,5 % de
la valeur ajouté de l'entreprise quel
que soit son chiffre d'affaires après
l'annonce de cette suppression partielle
les réactions se succèdent le président
de l'agglomération dénonce lui une
mesure démagogique il rappelle que la
taxe professionnelle pèse lourd dans le
budget de Saint-Quentin et finance
notamment les routes les transports et
les services publics les choix sont
complètement incohérents quandads
install la clé de Saint-Pierre la
première chose qu'il demande c'est de
doubler les services de transport à la
clé de Saint-Pierre et donc c'est c'est
un une contribution qui est efficace
dynamique dans l'investissement donc si
on le fait plus et ben on va à
l'encontre de l'objectif de dynamiser
l'investissement et de toute façon il
faudra bien payer les Pompi donc c'est
bien les les les contribuables de
Saint-Quentin qui payeront et ça
représente 1000 € par foyer autre
réaction celle du député maire UMP
d'lencour pour lui cette suppression
partielle de la TP vise d'abord à aider
les entreises à traversé la crise je
crois que c'est même François mitteran
qui disait que la taxe professionnelle
est un impôt imbécile bon sa je pense
qu'il y a un certain consensus de toute
façon la suprim en partie puisqu'on
garde la partie sur le sur le les locaux
en fait hein euh simplement il y aura il
y a un réaménagement de cette taxe il y
a la commission baladure qui travaille
là-dessus donc il a plusieurs pistes
enfin à eux de de de produire mais c'est
pas très difficile c'est pas très
complexe de de de de c'est pas très
complexe de créer des impôts de toute
façon mais le tout c'est qu'il soit plus
intelligent et qui et qui et qui ne
mettent moins en difficulté la
compétitivité de no entreprises enfin le
maire de manilé amau comme beaucoup
d'autres s'inquiète de la compensation
financière comme toutes les collectivés
comme SEP communes de ladelot je tousse
le froncier bâti des entreprises bon ça
ça ne changera pas si effectivement on
supprime la taxe professionnelle ou si
effectivement donc on va la
tripatouiller pour faire en sorte que
qu'elle soit encore donc diminuée on
voit bien comment on a réglé le budget
donc déjà 2009 hein ça pas été simple
hein donc pensez bien que donc je vois
pas comment on va pouvoir fonctionner on
va on va être tous en tu les
conséquences c'est évident la
suppression de la TP interviendra en
2010 elle sera évidemment compensé aux
collectivités locales a précisé François
Fillon alors on va aborder l'avenir mais
peut-être un mot sur cette suppression
de la la taxe professionnelle est-ce
qu'on a un peu de recul parce que là le
sujet daté de la décision est-ce qu'on a
un peu de recul pour savoir finalement
est-ce que c'est favorable aux
entreprises est-ce est que ça pèse sur
les collectivités mon point de vue c'est
que on a maintenant le recul pour dire
que ça été quand même une belle
improvisation h faut se remettre dans le
contexte de 2010 imaginez les
collectivités qui ne savaient pas
comment le budget 201122 et cetera
pourrait être formmer et puis une
succession de décisions de transfert
puisque la taxe d'habitation
départementale arrive maintenant à la
communauté d'agglomération les
entreprises qui payaient la taxe
professionnelle payent maintenant un
autre impôt mais les collectivités
locale comme la communauté
d'agglomération ne le touche plus on a
donc une compensation qui n'est pas
forcément assurée dans le temps donc des
inquiétudes voilà j'ai résumé en plus
vous imaginez que c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et qu'il nous a fallu
des heures pour arriver à comprendre un
petit peu les les les tonants les
aboutissants unot revira làdessus oui si
vous demandez à un chef d'entreprise qu'
pense de la taxe il vous dira que
il voilà non mais que sa douleur est
sans doute un peu attinuée si cette taxe
c'est bien réparti et utile y compris
dans la proximité et je crois que la
Chambre de Commerce de l'Industrie de
Versailles c'est impliqué à travers les
entreprises du département pour
corriger le premier j'allais dire la
première mouture de la réforme de la
taxe et et faire en sorte que on
aboutisse à quelque chose ce qui va
arriver dans le dans les quelques mois
qui viennent à quelque chose de plus
juste de mieux réparti et et sans doute
on l' esppère de plus directement
connecté à au territoire alors un mot
sur le développement économique en sur
ce qu'on peut attendre évidemment il y a
le lien avec le le Grand Paris qui qui
est très
important mais il y a aussi la crise qui
est là est-ce que est-ce que ça pose des
problèmes bien sûr la période que nous
venons de traversé depuis 2008 c'est une
période de crise on n'est pas un hîot
hors du monde donc on l'a bien sûr
ressenti je dirais que saquanteline a
sans doute mieux résister que d'autres
territoiression l'impression qu'on peut
avoir mais c'est c'est clairement le
l'impression qu'on peut avoir en
regardant même si on a eu quelques
entreprises en difficulté on a mieux
résisté parce que c'est vrai qu'au fil
des des ans le fait d'avoir des grands
groupes mais aussi ce tissu de moyennes
et petites entreprises qui s'est
développé a compté énormément et on a su
je pense ça c'est très important par
rapport à ces 40 ans que nous évoquons
on a su à la fois continuer à attirer de
nouvelles entreprises qui viennent
s'implanter sur des des assiettes de
terrain à 50 ieline tout en
s'intéressant de près à celle qui était
arrivé au tout début dans des bâtiments
qui sont maintenant vieillissants et
pour lesquels il faut créer une nouvelle
vie c'est-à-dire requalifier régénérer
transformer et là on est dans un
mouvement assez formidable au niveau de
50 ans iveline alors à la fois porté par
des entreprises elles-mêmes on a un
exemple illustre c'est par exemple
challenger bu qui est en train de de
reconditionner totalement son
équipement pour le mettre vraiment
au N nor voilà on a l'exemple de groupe
qui ont comme malakov meric il changent
d'immeuble il rentrent dans un immeuble
neuf et l'immeuble le plus ancien dans
lesquel il ils avaient démarré est
totalement reconditionné pour attirer un
autre groupe qui est déjà aussi sur le
territoire qui s'appelle égis et donc là
on a une dynamique extrêmement positive
un cercle vertueux qui fait
que les les
entreprises les entreprises vous
quittent pas mais en plus voilà les
entreprises ne nous quittent pas ell
elles font leur parcours résidentiel sur
50 ans d'Elin et en même temps ça permet
ça c'est très important et ça c'est
j'allais dire une des priorités pour la
période ça permet de requalifier et de
faire en sorte que notre tissu à la fois
de zone d'activité mais aussi d'immeuble
d'entreprise soit de nouveau attractif
comme au premiier jour avec des
immeubles extrêmement modernes adaptés
aux nouveaux besoins et correspondant à
ce que nous demandent les entreprises
alors je vais vous demander de une
conclusion dans quelques instants
justement sur sur bah ce qu'on peut
espérer pour l'avenir mais je voudrais
qu'on on vienent à quelque chose qui
vient d'être créé ou qui va être créé ça
s'appelle le carré privé c'est une
demande du public c'est une demande des
commerçants euh on va dire les deux
euh on s'inscrit sur cette même
dynamique de la communauté
d'agglomération donc voilà il fallait
mettre au goût du jour euh à la fois
l'espace SaintQuentin parce qu'on va
rénover l'espace SaintQuentin et à la
fois carré privé ouest euh en lui
proposant en fait quelque chose qui
n'existe pas dans l'Ouest parisien et
qui euh euh manque à ce tissu économique
oui voilà sur le le luxe version outlet
à l'anglais c'està-dire à - 30 % sur les
collections de l'année passée avec des
navettes des ouce ça va attirer
évidemment une population qui qui pas
seulement la population on est à 10
minutes du château de versaill donc
voilà on veut aussi se servir de cette
de cette Man et puis cette attractivité
de de 50 ans en diveline on est on va
accueillir aussi dans quelques années la
rider Cup voilà on en parlera parce
qu'on va faire une éion consacrée au
sport donc évidemment ça serait ça fait
partie des projets d'avenir de la
communauté euh pour conclure Henry
vatrin et François delignier sur voilà
les les l'économie telle qu'elle peut se
porter dans les années qui viennent
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
là-dessus en conclusion je dirais qu'on
a devant nous de de grands enjeux c'est
étonnant de se rappeler que au début de
la ville nouvelle il y avait une
opération d' interternationale et
aujourd'hui 550 aneline fait partie
d'une nouvelle opération d'intérêt
national celle du plateau de sa et on a
donc de grands enjeux à condition
évidemment et qu'on pourra réussir à
condition que l'État associe les élus
locaux que les territoires puissent être
partie prenante et que finalement entre
l'État et les collectivités il y a un
partenariat avec cet objectif faire en
sorte que pour 50 ans en Yveline pour le
plateau de saclet de manière plus
générale on puisse avoir un
développement harmonieux répondre aux
besoins en dialogue avec les entreprises
on parlait tout à l'heure de besoins de
logement on parlait de besoins de
service ça doit être porté par les
territoires on a donc un jeu formidable
qui est lié aussi à l'arrivée espéré
attendu mais pas encore financé de la
ligne verte dans le cadre de du Grand
Paris qui peut là aussi pour les
entreprises être déterminante parce que
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure les
enjeux de déplacement font aussi partie
de nos préoccupation donc on peut se
tourner vers la décennie qui vient avec
avec un peu d'espoir avec un peu
d'espoir et surtout beaucoup à faire et
beaucoup à faire hen sur sur cet avenir
la chambre de commerceindustrie de
Versailles a été associé par le passé au
développement on a souhaité avec la
communauté d'agglomération intensifier
un petit peu notre effort en y donnant
un cadre plus plus dynamique qui est
celui d'une convention entre la
Communauté de l'agglomération et la CCI
la communauté d'agglomération je dire
pilotant le développement et la CCI
faisant valoir comme c'est son rôle les
aspirations des entreprises les grandes
les petites les industries les commerces
l'artisanat les services et c'est bien
dans ce sens-là que nous allons
travailler en ce qui concerne
l'aménagement en ce qui concerne les
réseaux et en ce qui concerne l'aide aux
entreprises on a déjà commencé il faut
intensifier cet effort pour avoir un
développement encore plus harmonieux
merci beaucoup
jeanljouter un mot non je crois tout a
été dit sur tout a été dit il bien dit
merci infiniment à tous les quatre merci
et à très vite pour un nouveau
rendez-vous sur les 40 ans de
Saint-Quentin en
Éveline
[Musique]